con come
fa Bat
po
e
Meso
sempre B problema
claa cons
Esse teste do éa desafio desf
Aho
OST
isosta compesso
seesso
Inas
chi
o come si chiama cio sicura
Fura Vai
Spar Allora Caio per
favore
B
allora
e olistico o Esi e o Eh verd sì es e p
es e p
Allora
gira
pug
B
anora assunto magica esempio muscolo
frag che non frag
con
cza con
Nonis un
problema è un muscolo fondament
daa
nost
che è una cosa
fantastica un testus
conas buc
smaa
responsab
frisas test cruso volta
forte
eamo stent
C diciamo la logica test perché test
Allora nost amico Caio è
frago
frago FR
la è amic
[Musica]
amico
FR
contraria
problema problema con
muscolo volta
fortea
muscolo SC un
Challenge
funzionamento e
come Sì
sì
St
scher prto
Sì non
èi perta
CAI FR m
[Musica]
SIM Tem que falar Em voz alta Isso Como
a pergunta faz Em voz alta
oue
se pensamento
prici
Esiste
un è come un assunto de centesimo maaco
e esiste una una specie di conen
Universal non sapevo F Eh non sapevo fig
cioè lo Spen C sape già che è con con
una conion Universal o campo morfogeno è
Iso no si chiama subcosciente universale
si chiama sub Universal Chama
Chiama fisica guanci spo per esempio
fenom entanglement SAP entang
Sango
maraio Pega una
parcola di un atomo Eh e dà
un'informazione
acicula Bota No è allora
un atomo una parcola una parcola b aas
parcas e d informazione a una particola
parcola
che non
SAP
pazione è fisica qu
Stud non quelle io sol sol
penso se Iso se Iso volta forte
e
or
[ __ ]
mous mous
pronto è
stran perché è important se perché già
sei
pazien un problema di es perché perché
facendo un test olistico con muscolo
Force muscolo Force ficò frago
noesi Prim testi bucaro caso un pisato
che volta Force coesi due stesti che va
da confirma un problema Sì è un du
stti
test du Mati
che diagnos
duas Poe sta una Fis sta da
Bascio una una quadra Come si
Chama scriv con significa in italiano
volta Force con con
eh scriv
es
o
C scollare una
s
e
bu neurolog Sì
sta
neurologico
è no C dato Sì sì C
datoci girac sto mostrando perché una
consulta per un poco
differer non
seag
pronto
Eh no
pima e for p Sima is
frago Allora mio dolato Di schero
Vaio forse Orato gireto
Vai
FR che temo studi si è un p si è un Esi
si è un le Sol che
grande
confusus
una
non Nunca do nunc
do ex
AG apprend che Crus con m m
che stato muscolare e Fort
muscolo un Vai buare Sma sai che St
facendo un er con
certeza
Allora lato Gir gireto
frago
gireto
for
schema
crociato
es volte volta forte non sai se è volta
forte
la già pronto Frezza for non
Sezza muscol Eh sta sendo la differenza
eh sta sendo
Lazza muscolo
eest impur impura impur e non è op
perché St Uma il P Caio non è op è Uma
che stava O
D Isso ficou forte Com segurando a
estrutura fou é O D pode Uma Vai para
E
para
perch
lato si è
crociato pronto
in
no FR
Quest No no è for
crociato ma a non è Crus Total sta
compensando
esempio
frag non FR
ainda
év T ruim
é Iso
comica
che
unesti e la te perché te una Come si
Chama tero e Pedra prote terzo
uhum bon bon C per Fav C un
momento la seconda
colonna la seconda colna c paciente
certo relio
Famila segunda professor antes Sen
segunda leva FOI falou leva Eu quereria
segunda fale segunda leva falou na
segunda sei O que segunda columna
segunda colum
da colum antes de Show Comear crepar sua
gentileza Eu fiquei com dvida para
entender o teste
cruzado te most tranquilo
Ok T usato esiste su una chinesiologia
medica non sta una chinesiologia
applicata non esiste chinesiologia
applicata un tema smas non con SM già
app non cons
usato usato è una un trucchi Busca Azza
muscolo TR strat truc strateg
strat
che o p o b o o v o non Sap St e già sei
che
Caio du muscol frag du muscol importan
che stao sempre che studiare una fiscia
FR Culpa Esi
Gi sto scassando la Sebola sta
intendendo Cont sto
entrando scc Sebola scassando la Sebola
Allora seconda columna se è nata
Eh cando
per
esempio perché sia Cont che qualche cosa
Bu io posso pensare
che
causa di
Pisa devo rapido Perché già sai che
mutata ma
esempio Come si chiama lo complimento SP
è sempre uguale
e qu
sei è mesmo
eh
inon
Camo non è important che non
eh non sai che fa la
capesa la capesa Quanto fai 40 45 4 45
45 e ind 45
45 aumenta un poco no 45 Eh mesma mesma
sì lo spunto da STAV
natata rapido
eh rapidino
Nada
senta
nonte
mesmo
faz to vez que Eu pass sa quando El
volta
faz
[Musica]
Mes olistico
hum bom
impura Alora
G fecha Olas D Sem
contato
bom
b b
b s
s
interen ter
teratologico
no e meto è igual
ma ok e qu
significato
che come si
Chama terno
Sì terzo terzo Sì terzo Sì
conesso non par era nessuna FCE di
disturbio perché era non migliorò No Er
mesma non Mut non migliorò non migliorò
semea
capza potemo farl che o
CPO
innocen and è normale perché è Sol no
sol un terzo non è solo terzo un terzo
valore
spiritual Mas nona sì El usando é Ela
pode est usando atrapalhada Ela
atrapalhar Como como na guerra e Mas
pode dizer também que que faz diferen Ou
deixa de ajudar Ou
ajuda Isso para Fazer Isso Tem que
esperar SIM ainda um paiho de de Mod
para para que a gente possa explicar
acha que pode ajudar Mas pode saber pode
ver
S por meio de para saber né mesmo que
ensine a eles para saber se a
Eh problemaa
e
seemp
terzo
problema Problema
Poo non consig
adess un problema spiritual per terzo
per un problema
Dea de Macumba eh Tip
Mater r r r
ci most fin consulta Che
fac Allianza siamo sempre
odti non infetto una postura ma non
infetto energia
non